He is the journey of the mind.
This is what determines the journey of
life.
Have you ever had the feeling that your
mind is on a journey of voyage,
of discovery,
that sometimes it has to make long
passages on dark,
uncharted seas and at other times and
discovers bright islands of beauty or of
truth I haven't zipped.
We'll know from this day forward then it
can always steer for him.
Find in a storm while they gales of
life,
blow themselves out of me.
Enormous sees of misfortune or pain or
sorrow or doubt subside in the calm.
Well,
if you will come,
I'd like to take you with me on such a
voyage of the mind.
That one that was charted for me many
years ago by an obscure English editor
and poet named James Allen and a little
book called as a man Thinketh,
that word you will hear essentially
those of James Allen's as a man
thinketh,
thought in character.
The aphorism as a man thinketh in his
heart,
so is he not only embraces the whole of
a man's being,
but it's so comprehensive as to reach
out to every condition and circumstance
of his life.
A man is literally what he thinks.
His character being the complete sum of
all his thoughts as the plant springs
from and could not be without the seed.
So the acts of the man's spring from the
hidden seeds of thought and could not
have appeared without them.
The suppliers to those acts called the
spontaneous and unpremeditated as well
as to those which are deliberately
executed.
Act is the blossom of thought and joy
and suffering are its fruits.
That's doesn't matter.
Garner in the sweet and bitter footage
of his own husbandry thought in the mind
have made us what we are by thought was
rock and built.
If a man is mine have evil thoughts,
pain comes on him as comes.
That we only ox behind that if man and
deere is in purity of thought,
joy follows him as his own shadow.
Sure man grows by law,
not by artifice and cause an effect on
us.
Absolute and I'm deviating and they
hidden realm of thought as in the world
of visible and material things.
A noble character is not a thing of
favor or chance,
but it's the natural result of continued
effort and thought the effect of long
cherished association with high ideals
and ignoble and best Joel character,
but the same process as the result of
the continued,
the heartbreak of grumbling thoughts man
is made or unmade by
in the armory of thought.
He forges the weapons by which he
destroys himself.
He also patients the tools with which he
builds for himself.
Heavenly mentions of joy and strength
and peace made the right choice and true
application of thought man,
a to our divine perfection by the abuse
and wrong application of thought.
He descends below the level of the beast
between these two extremes are all the
grades of character and men is their
maker and master
of all the beautiful truth pertaining to
this,
so all of which have been restored and
brought to light.
None as mark broadening our food full of
divine promise and confidence than this.
That man is the master of thought.
The motor of character and the maker and
shaper of condition and environment and
destiny
as a being a power,
intelligence and love and the Lord of
his own thoughts.
Man holds the key to every situation and
contains where they himself,
that transforming and regenerative
agency by which he may make himself what
he wills.
Then as always the master,
even in his weakest and most abandoned
state but in weakness and degradation is
not foolish.
Master who miss governs his household.
When he begins to reflect upon his
condition and to search diligently for
the law upon which is being as
established,
he then becomes the wise master
directing his images with intelligence
and fashioning his thoughts to fruitful
issues such as the conscious master and
then can only does become by discovering
within himself the laws of thought,
which discovery is totally a matter of
application,
self analysis and experience only by
much searching and mining are golden
diamonds have tamed and man confined
every truth connected with his being.
If he will dig deep into the mind of his
soul and that he is the maker of his
character,
the molder of his life.
And the builder of his destiny.
He may unerringly Bruv if he will watch
control and ultra his thoughts tracing
their effects upon himself Abramovich
and upon his life and circumstances,
linking cause and effect by patient
practice and investigation and utilizing
his every experience even to the most
trivial,
everyday occurrence as a means of
obtaining that knowledge of himself,
which is understanding wisdom.
Power in this direction as in no other
is the law.
Absolute that P that secret findeth and
to him that knocks it shall be opened
our only by patients practice and the
ceaseless importuning can a man enter
the door of the temple of knowledge
of the mind.
It obeys the orders of the mind,
whether they be deliberate or automatic
at the bidding of evil,
miserable thoughts.
Their body may sink rapidly in the
disease and decay at the command of glad
and beautiful thoughts.
It make clothe itself with the
youthfulness and beauty disease and
health like circumstances are often
rooted in thought.
Six thoughts may express themselves
through a sick body.
In Aboriginal Society.
It starts a fair,
the known to kill a man as speedily as a
bullet and they are continually killing
thousands of people in our society.
Justice surely though less rapidly,
people who live in fear of disease are
apt to become out anxiety quickly.
The modernizers,
the whole body and lazy it open to
illness and disease while evil thoughts,
even though they be no more than that,
we'll soon shatter the nervous system.
Strong,
pure and happy thoughts build bigger and
grace.
The body is that sensitive plastic
instrument which responds readily did
that thoughts by which of his government
and having some thoughts.
We'll produce that on effects,
good or bad.
Apartment out of a clean mind comes a
clean life and a clean body.
Out of a defiled mind proceeds a defined
life and a corrupt body thought is the
fount of action,
life and manifestation.
Make the founder of the pier and the
stream of life of flow with greater
purity,
change of diet.
Maybe it'll help.
Amanda will not change your thoughts
when a man makes his thoughts healthy.
He no longer designers.
I'm healthy.
Food,
clean thoughts make clean,
healthy habits.
The so called saint who doesn't have to
wash his body,
he may well not be a saint.
And if you would perfect your body,
God,
your mind,
if you would renew your body,
beautify your mind.
Thoughts of malice in the
disappointment,
despondency can rob your body of it's
health and grace.
A sour face does not come by chance.
It has made my salad thoughts,
wrinkles that mar are drawn by folly,
pride and passion.
I know a woman of 96 who has the bright
innocent face of a girl.
I know a man well under the middle age
whose faces drawn into inharmonious kind
of two areas.
The one is the result of us,
so even a sunny disposition.
The others,
the outcome of bad temper and discontent
as you cannot have a suite and wholesome
abode unless you admit the air and
sunshine freely in the or rooms.
So a strong body and a bright,
happy,
serene condiments can only result from
my free admittance into the mind of
thought,
some joy and goodwill and serenity on
the faces of the age.
There are wrinkles made by sympathy.
There's by strong impure thought and
others are carved by arrogance and
resentment who cannot distinguish them,
what those have lived thoughtfully.
Agent's calm,
peaceful and softly mellow like the
setting sun.
I have recently seen a philosopher on
his death bed.
He was not a old except in years he
died.
The sweeper,
he and peacefully as he's lived,
there is no physician like cheerful
thought for dissipating the ills of
malcontent.
There is a comparator to compare with
goodwill,
for dispersing the shadows of grief and
Sarah to have continually in thoughts of
ill will,
cynicism,
suspicion and mv is to be confined in a
self made me prison hall,
but to think well of all to be cheerful
with all just patiently learned to find
the good in all is to live in sight of
the very portals of heaven and they buy
the thoughts of peace start.
Every creature will bring a bounding
piece to that possessor
thought and circumstances,
a man's mind and maybe likened it to a
garden which may be intelligently
cultivated or allowed to run wild,
but when it comes invaded or neglected,
it must end,
will bring forth.
If no useful seeds I put into it,
then an abundance of useless weed seeds
will fall there and we'll continue to
produce that kind of justice at.
Gardener cultivates his plot,
keeping it free from weeds and growing
the flowers and fruits which he
requires.
So many young men tend the garden of his
mind.
We had all the wrong and useless
thoughts and cultivating toward
perfection,
the flowers and fruits to ripe,
useful and pure thoughts.
My pursuing this process,
a man sooner or later discovers that he
is the master gardener of his soul,
the director of his life.
He also reveals within himself the laws
of thought and understands with ever
increasing accuracy how his mind
operates in the sheep.
We have his character,
circumstances and destiny.
Thought and character are one and as
character can only manifest and
discovered itself to environment and
circumstance,
the outer conditions of a person's life
will always be found to be related to
his inner state.
This does not mean that a man of
circumstances at any given time or an
indication of his entire character,
but that those circumstances are so
intimately connected with some vital
thought within himself that for the time
being they are indispensable to his
development.
Every man is where he is by the law of
his being.
The thoughts which he has built into his
character have brought him there and in
the arrangement of his life there is no
lasting element of champs,
but all is the result of a law which
cannot bear.
This is just as true of those who are
discontented with their surroundings as
of those who are contented with them.
As an evolving being man is where he is,
that he may learn that he may grow and
as he learns the lesson which any
circumstance contains for him,
it passes away and give spice to other
circumstances.
Man is buffeted by circumstances so long
as he believes himself to be a creature
and currently subject to outside
conditions.
But when he realizes that he is a
creative power and that he made command
the hidden soil and seeds of his being,
how to avoid circumstances grow,
he then becomes the right full master of
himself that circumstances grow out of
thought.
Every man knows who has for any length
of time,
practice,
self control of his mind and thoughts
for he will live.
Notice that the alteration of his
circumstances has been an exact ratio
with is altered mental condition.
So true is this,
that when a man earnestly applies
himself to remedy the defects in his
character and make swift and mark the
progress,
he passes rapidly through a succession
of this institutes that so attracts
lack,
which is secretly hybrids,
that which it loves,
and also that which it fears.
It reaches the height of his cherished
aspirations.
It falls to the level of its unchaste
desires and circumstances are the means
by which the soul receives its own and
we thought seeds sown are allowed to
fall into the mind and to take root
there producers a tone blossoming sooner
or later in the act and bearing its own
food,
age of opportunity in circumstance,
good thoughts,
bear good fruit,
bad thoughts,
bad trip.
The outer world of circumstances shaped
by the inner world of thought and both
pleasant and unpleasant external
conditions or factors which make for the
ultimate good of the individual.
As the reaper of his own harvest man
learns both by suffering and bliss
following me in most desires,
aspirations,
thoughts by which he allows himself to
be dominated,
pursuing me will the West sort of vapor,
the imaginings are steadfast.
We walking the highway of strong and
high end ever a man at last arrives at
their fruition and fulfillment in the
outer conditions of his life.
The laws of growth and adjustment
everywhere.
Obtain a man does not come to the arms
house,
so the jail by the tyranny of fate or
circumstance,
but by the pathway of grovelling
thoughts and base desires,
nor does a high minded men fall.
Suddenly the crime by stress am a mere
external force.
The criminal thoughts have long been
secretly fostered in the heart when the
hour of opportunity you'd be able to,
it's gathered power circumstance does
not make the man.
It reveals
no such conditions can exist as
defending and device and its attendant
sufferings apart from vicious
inclinations or ascending into virtue
and it's happiness without the continued
cultivation of virtuous aspirations.
And then they have Laura as the Lord and
Master of thought is the maker of
himself,
the shaper and author of environment.
The soul comes to its own.
Through every step of the jeffery
pilgrimage.
It attracts those combinations of
conditions which reveal itself,
which are the reflections of its own
virtue and vice.
It's strength and weakness.
Men did not attract that which they say
they want,
but that could stay are their whims
fancies and ambitions are taught it.
At every step,
but they're in most parts and desires
are fed with the food of their own
choosing the divinity,
the chiefs,
our ams is in ourselves.
It is our very self man is manacle only
by himself.
Thought and action are the jailers of
fate.
They imprison being based that also the
angels of freedom.
They liberate being no book,
not what he wishes him praise for it as
a man get,
but what he justly earns.
His wishes and prayers are only
gratified and answered when they comport
with his thoughts and actions in the
light of this truth.
What then is the meaning of fighting
against circumstances?
It means that a man has continually
revolting against an effect without wet
all the time.
He is nourishing and preserving its
cause in his heart.
That caused me to take the form of a
conscious vice or an unconscious
weakness,
but whatever it is,
it's stubbornly returns the efforts of
its possessor and thus calls allowed the
remedy.
Men are anxious to improve their
circumstances,
but are unwilling to improve themselves.
They therefore remain bound,
but names will,
does not shrink from self sacrifice,
can never fail to accomplish.
The object upon which he was hard is
that this is as true of material as of
spiritual things.
Even the man who was so object is to
acquire wealth and must be prepared to
make great personal sacrifices.
We've already can accomplish this object
and how much marcel he would realize a
happy,
joyful life.
It was a man who is wretchedly poor,
is extremely anxious that his
surroundings and home comfort should be
improved it all the time.
He shirks his work and considers these
justified in trying to deceive his
employer on the ground of the
insufficiency of his wages.
Such a man does not understand the
simplest rudiments of those principles,
which are the basis of true prosperity
and there's not only totally unfitted
derives out of his wretchedness,
but it's actually attracting to himself
a student deeper wretchedness by
dwelling m and acting out in Dulles
deceptive and a memory thought he was a
rich man who was the victim of a painful
and persistent ill health as a result of
glutimate.
He's willing to give large sums of money
to get rid of it,
but he will not abandon his gluttony.
He wants to gratify his taste for rich
and harmful volumes and have his health
as well.
Such a man is totally unfit to have help
because he has not yet learned the first
principles of a healthy life.
Here's my employer of labor who adopts
crooked measures to avoid paying the
regulation wage and in the hope of
making larger profits.
We do says the wages of his work,
people such a man as altogether unfitted
for prosperity and when he finds himself
bankrupt both as regards reputation and
bridges,
he blames circumstances not knowing that
he is the sole author of his condition.
I've introduced these three cases nearly
as illustrative of the truth.
That man is the causer.
They'll nearly always unconscious way of
his circumstances and that while aiming
at a good and he may continually
frustrated it's accomplishment.
My thoughts and desires,
which cannot possibly harmonize with
that end in such cases could be
multiplied in varied almost
indefinitely,
but this is not necessarily as you can
if he still is the action of the laws of
thought in your own mind in life.
I'm telling you,
do this near external facts are not
likely to persuade you.
Circumstances however,
are so complicated.
Thought is so deeply rooted in the
conditions of happiness,
very so with individuals that a man's
entire condition,
although it may be now under himself,
cannot be judged by another from the
external aspect of his life alone.
A man may be honest in certain
directions,
it's separate privations and man,
they be dishonest in certain directions,
yet acquire wealth.
The conclusion usually formed however,
that the one man fails because of his
particular honesty and that the other
prospers because of his particular
dishonesty is the result of a
superficial judgment,
which assumes that the dishonest man is
almost totally corrupt and the honest
man almost entirely virtuous in the
light of a deeper knowledge and wider
experience.
Such judgment is found to be around
this.
But dishonest man,
they have some admirable virtues which
the other does not possess.
And the honest man,
obnoxious devices which are absent in
the other.
The honest man rapes the good results.
So designers,
thoughts and acts.
He also brings upon himself the
sufferings,
which is vice's and the dishonest man.
Likewise,
gun has his own sufferings and happiness
and it's pleasing the human vanity to
believe that one suffers because of
one's virtue,
but not have them tell.
A man has extubated every vicious,
bitter and resentful thought from his
mind.
Can he be in a position to know and
declare that his sufferings are the
result of is good and not of his
bad qualities?
And on the way to yet long before it has
reached that supreme perfection,
he will have found working in his mind
in life the great law,
which is absolutely just in which cannot
therefore give good for evil,
evil for good,
possessing such knowledge.
He will then know,
looking back upon this past ignorant and
blindness that his life is and always
was justly ordered and that all his past
experiences.
Good and bad,
where the equitable outworking of his
evolving yet unevolved good thoughts and
actions can never in the long run and
produce bad results,
bad thoughts and actions can never
produce good results.
This has been saying that nothing can
come from corn,
but corn,
nothing from metals,
but metals.
Men understand this law and the natural
world and work with it,
but few understand it and the mental and
moral world though it's operation.
The hair is just as simple and I'm
deviating and they therefore do not
cooperate with it.
Mental suffering is always the effect of
error in some direction,
and it's an indication that the
individual is out of harmony with
himself,
with the law of his being the sole.
I'm supreme you.
So such suffering is to correct and
teach mental suffering ceases or him who
was wise.
There can be no object burning gold
after the drug has been removed and the
mind of a perfectly enlightened beings
cannot be agonized.
The circumstances which Amanda
encounters with suffering of the result
of his own bleak outlook.
The circumstances which amendment
counters with blessedness or again the
result of his own aptitude,
blessedness,
not material possessions is the measure
of right wretchedness,
not the lack of material possessions is
the major of wrong.
A man may be cursed and rich.
He may be blessed and poor blessedness
and enriches only join together when the
richards or wisely used and the poor man
old me descends into wretchedness when
he regards his life as a Britain
unjustly imposed in the gym.
Some indulgence are the two extremes of
wretchedness.
They're both equally unnatural.
A man is not rightly conditioned until
he's a happy,
healthy,
and prosperous being.
And happiness.
Health and prosperity are the results of
a harmonious adjustment of the inner
with the outer of the man,
with his surroundings.
A man only begins to be a man when he
sees us,
don't whine and revile and commenced
this to search where they hidden
justice,
which regulates his life.
And as he adapts his mind too,
that regulating factor,
he ceases to accuse others as the cause
of his condition.
And built himself up in strong and
noble.
Thoughts ceases to kick against
circumstances,
but begins to use them as aids to his
more rapid progress and as a means of
discovering the hidden powers and
possibilities within himself.
Law Not confusion is that dominating
principle in the universe.
Justice,
not injustice is the sum and substance
of life and righteousness,
not corruption is the molding and moving
forest in the spiritual government of
the world.
This being so Manhattan,
but to write himself to find that the
university's right and during the
process of putting himself right,
he will find that as he alters his
thoughts towards situations and other
people situations and other people will
alter your toward him.
The proof of this truth is in every
person and that therefore admits them.
Easy investigation by systematic
introspection and self analysis and a
man radically alter his thoughts and he
will be astonished that the rapid
transformation that will affect in the
material conditions of his life.
Imagine that thought can be kept secret,
but it cannot.
It rapidly crystallizes into habit and
habits solidifies in just circumstance.
Thoughts of fear,
doubt and indecision crystallize into
week unmanly and irresolute habits,
which solidify in the circumstances of
failure.
Indigents and slavish dependence,
lazy,
apathetic,
thought's crystallizing the habits of
disorder.
I'm climbing there some dishonesty we
solidify in the circumstances of
confusion,
fallenness and beggary resentful and we
condemn monetary thought's,
crystallizing the habits of accusation
and violence,
which solidify in the circumstances of
hate,
injury and persecution.
On the other hand,
beautiful thoughts of all kinds of
crystallize and the habits and grace and
timeliness which to defined a genial and
sunny circumstances.
Selfless thought's crystallizing the
habits of temporary,
some self control which solidify in the
circumstances of risk,
pros and peace,
thoughts of courage,
self reliance and decision crystallized
into manly habits which solidify under
circumstances of strength and freedom
and energetic thought's crystallizing
the habits of industry,
which sort of divide and the
circumstances of achievement kind and
loving thoughts,
crystallizing the habits of
considerateness for others which
solidify and the circumstances of a
biting comfort.
A particular train of thought persisted
and be it good or bad,
cannot fail to produce it through south.
So character in sexual stances and man,
can I directly choose his circumstances,
but he can choose his thoughts and so
indirectly yet surely shape their
circumstances.
Make your health every man to the
gratification of the thoughts which he
most encourages and opportunities are
presented,
which were most speedily bring to the
service,
both the good and evil thoughts.
Imam choose his thoughts wisely and all
the world will soften toward him and be
ready to help him.
Let him put away bad thoughts and low
opportunities or spring up on every
hand.
The aid is strong results.
Nothing even encourage good thoughts and
no hard fate.
Chub binding them down to wretchedness
and shit.
The world is your kaleidoscope,
the varying combinations of which it
every succeeding moment it presents to
you as the exquisitely adjusted pictures
of your ever moving thought
you will be what you will to be let
failure find.
It's false content in that poor word
environment,
but spirits scorns it and it's free.
It masters time,
it conquers space.
It cows that boastful texted champs and
bibs the terror of circumstance.
I'm the crown and fill a servant's
place.
The human will that force unseen.
The offspring of a deathless soul can
hew a way to any goal.
The walls of granite intervene be not
impatient in delay,
but wait as one who understands when
spirit rises and commands,
the Gods are ready to obey
thought purpose and achievement
until thought is linked with purpose.
There is no intelligent accomplishment
with the majority.
The park daughters allowed to drift upon
the ocean of life.
Aimlessness is advice and such.
Drifting must not continue for him.
I would steer clear of catastrophe and
destruction.
They who have no central purpose in
their life,
following easy prey to petty worries,
fears,
troubles himself could headings,
all of which are indications of
weakness,
which lean just to Shirley is deliberate
wrongdoing by a different route to
failure,
unhappiness and loss for weakness cannot
persist in a power evolving universe.
A man should conceive of a worthy
purpose in his heart and set up to
accomplish it.
You should make this purpose the
centralizing point of his thoughts.
It may take the form of a spiritual
ideal or it may be a worldly object
according to his nature at the time,
but whichever it is,
he should have steadfastly focused his
thoughts upon the object which he has
set before him.
He should make this purpose is supreme
duty and should devote himself to its
attainment,
not allowing his thoughts to wander away
and the vague and if female offenses,
this is the royal road to self control
and true concentration of thought.
Even if he fails again,
again to accomplish his purpose as he
necessarily master drove weaknesses,
overcome the spring third character he
dreams will be the measure of its true
success and this will form a new
starting point for future power and
tramp.
Those who are not prepared to conceive
and dedicate themselves to a great
purpose should fix that.
Thoughts upon the fault was performance
of their beauty.
No matter how significant bed tasks may
appear,
only in his wake and the thoughts began
there and focused and resolution that
energy be developed,
which being done there is nothing that
may not be accomplished.
The weakest will knowing its own
weakness and believing this truth,
that strength can only be developed by
effort in practice,
will thus believing at once begin to
exert itself and add the effort,
effort patients to patients from
strength to strength will never cease to
develop and will it last grow strong as
the physically weak man can make himself
strong by careful impatient exercise.
So the man and we thought it can become
strong by training himself in thinking
to put away aimlessness and weakness and
to begin this think with purpose is to
enter the ranks of those strong ones who
only recognize failure as one of the
pathway is to attain them who make all
conditions,
serve them and do things strongly
attempt fearlessly and accomplish
masterfully.
Having conceived of his purpose,
a man should prudently mark out a
straight pathway to its achievement.
Looking neither to the right nor the
left doubts and fears should be
rigorously excluded.
They are disintegrating elements which
break up the straight line of effort,
rendering it crooked,
ineffectual,
useless thoughts of doubt and fear never
accomplished anything and never cam.
They always lead to failure,
purpose them energy or weakened when
doubt and fear creeping up the will to
do springs to my knowledge that we can
do doubt and fear of the great enemies
of this knowledge and he would encourage
them forts himself at every step.
He who has conquered doubt and fear has
conquered failure is every thought is
fraught with power,
is difficulties wisely.
Bravely met an overcoat is purposes or
seasonably planted and the boom and
bring forth fruit which does not fall
prematurely to the ground thought allied
fearlessly to purpose becomes creative
force.
He who knows this is ready to become
something higher and stronger than a
mere bundle of wavering thoughts and
fluctuating sensations.
He who does this has become the
conscious and intelligent wielder of his
mental powers
over the amount of cheese at all he
fails to achieve is the direct result of
his own thoughts and adjust the ordered
universe where loss of repose means
destruction.
Individual responsibility must be
absolute a man's weakness and strength,
wisdom and follow his own right and not
another man.
They have a product of himself and not
another,
and they can only be ordered by himself,
never buy another is circumstances also
on his own and not another man.
His suffering and his happiness,
we evolved from within as he thinks so
is he.
As he continues to think so,
he remains
strong.
Man cannot help a weaker unless the
weaker is willing to be helped and even
then that week,
man must become strong of himself.
He must by his own efforts develop the
strength which he admires and another
none but himself can alter his
condition.
It has been unusual for Amanda thinking
to say many men are slaves because one
is an oppressor.
Let us hate the oppressor.
However,
there is a Mayan increasing few,
a tendency to reverse this judgment and
to say one man is an oppressor because
many are slaves that has despised the
slaves.
The truth is that a presser and Suede,
our cooperators and ignorance and the
Yoc,
I mean to reflect each other in reality
of the funeral was out.
It.
Perfect knowledge precedes the action of
law and the weakness of the oppressed
and the misapplied power of the
oppressor.
A perfect love seeing the suffering
which both states and tail condemns
neither a perfect compassion and basis.
Both oppressor and oppressed eus
conquered weakness and has put away
selfish thoughts,
belongs neither to oppress her nor
oppressed.
He has free.
A man can only rise,
conquer,
and achieve.
By lifting up his thoughts,
he can only remain weak and object and
miserable by refusing to lift up his
thoughts
before Amanda can achieve anything,
even in the world if things he must lift
his thoughts above the animal level,
he may not in order to succeed,
give up all an amount of ego.
Selfish does by any means,
but a portion of it at least must be
sacrificed.
A man who was Chris' daughter,
self indulgence can either think clearly
and our plan methodically,
he cannot find them.
Developers,
Lakeland grease sources,
and I must fail in any undertaking I've
having commenced from men from eight to
control his thoughts.
He's not in a position to control
affairs and to adopt serious
responsibilities.
He's not fed to act independently in
standalone.
He's limited by the thoughts where she
chooses.
There can be no progress,
no achievement without sacrifice and a
man's worldly success will be in the
measure that he sacrifices his confused
animal thoughts and fixes his mind on
the development of this plans and the
strengthening of his resolution and self
reliance and the higher he lifts his
thoughts,
the more manly and upright he becomes.
The greater will be his success.
The more blessed than enduring will be
as achievement.
The universe does not favor the greedy,
the dishonest the fishes.
Although on the mirror surface it may
sometimes appear to do so.
It's continuing.
A Beckman is what the honesty,
the magnanimous,
the virtuous,
all the great teachers,
the ages have declared this and varying
forms and approve and know it.
A man has been to persist and lifting up
his thoughts.
Intellectual achievements are the
results of thought consecrated to the
search for knowledge or for the
beautiful and true in life and nature.
Such achievements maybe sometimes
connected with vanity and ambition,
but they're not the outcome of those
characteristics.
They have a natural outgrowth of long
and arduous effort and arduous searching
thought.
Spiritual achievement is the
consummation of aspiration.
He who lives constantly and the
conception of wise and noble thoughts or
dwellings dwells upon all that is
elevating and himself as well.
As surely as this time reaches it's Dean
and the moon,
it's will become knowledgeable and noble
and rise into a position of wisdom and
blessedness,
achievement of whatever kind is the
crown of effort,
the diadem of thought by self control,
resolution at auditions and well
directed thought a man sm by an amount
of the endurance,
corruption and confusion of God.
Amen.
May Rise to highest success in the
world.
Andrew luck the altitudes in the
spiritual realm and again descend into
weakness and wretchedness by allowing
arrogant,
selfish,
and corrupt thoughts to take possession
of it.
The victory is attained by thought can
only be maintained by watchfulness many
giveaway when success is assured and
rapidly fall back into failure.
Achievement,
whether an a business,
intellectual or spiritual world is the
result of definitely directed thought is
governed by the same law and dependent
upon the same method.
The only difference lies in the object
of a payment.
He who had accomplished little needs
sacrifice level II who would achieve
much with sacrifice much.
He who would attain highly resacrifice
greatly
vision and ideals,
the visionaries of the saviors of the
world as the visible world is sustained
by the end of visible.
So men who all their trials and fins and
sordid vocations are nourished by the
beautiful vision was of their sanitary
dreamers.
Humanity cannot forget it's dreamers.
It can not let their ideas fade and die.
It lives in the moment it feels in them.
The reality is which it shower one day.
See and no composer,
sculptor,
painter,
poet,
prophet,
sage,
these are the architects of paradise.
The world is beautiful because they have
lived without them.
The laboring humanity would perish.
Eagle cherishes a beautiful vision,
a lofty idea of in his heart will one
day realize it.
Columbus cherish the vision of another
world and he discovered it.
Copernicus foster that vision of a
multiplicity of worlds and a wider
universe and he revealed it.
Buddha,
we held a vision of a spiritual world,
of stainless beauty in perfect peace.
And he entered into it.
Cherish your vision.
Cherish your ideals.
Cherish the music that stirs in your
heart,
the beauty that forms in your mind,
the loveliness that drapes your purest
thoughts for out of the [inaudible].
All delightful conditions,
all heavenly environment out,
please if you but remain true to them,
your world.
What are the last to be built to?
Desire is to obtain,
to aspire is to achieve,
shall ma'am spaces desire as received,
the fullest measure of gratification and
his highest aspiration starve for lack
of festivals such as not the law.
Such a condition of things can never
obtain.
Ask and receive
dream lofty dreams.
And as you dream,
so shall you become your vision is the
promise of what you shall one day be.
Your ideal is the prophecy of what you
shall.
At last unveil.
The greatest achievement was at first
and for a time a dream.
The Oak Sleeps in the Acorn,
the bird weights in the egg,
and in the highest vision of the soul,
a waking angel stairs.
Dreams are the seedlings of realities.
Your circumstances maybe uncongenial but
they shall not long remain.
So have you went perceive an ideal and
strive to reach it.
You cannot travel with them and stand
still without.
It was a youth hard pressed by poverty
and labor confined long hours in an
unhealthy workshop unschooled and
lacking all the arts,
but he brings a better things.
He thinks of intelligence,
of refinements,
of grace and beauty.
He conceives of mentally builds up an
ideal life.
The vision of a wider liberty and a
larger scope takes possession of it.
Unrest,
urges him to action and he utilizes all
his time and means small,
low.
They are to the development of his
latent powers and resources very soon so
altered.
It has his mind become that the workshop
can no longer hold him.
It has become so out of harmony with his
mentality that it falls out of his life
as a garment is cast aside and with the
growth of opportunities which fit the
scope of his expanding in better the a
passes out of it forever.
Years later we see this youth as a full
grown man.
We find them a master of certain forces
which he wheels with worldwide influence
and almost unequal power in his hands.
He holds the cards of gigantic
responsibilities.
He speaks and low lives are changed.
Men and women hang up on his words and
we mold their characters and the
sunlight.
It becomes the fixed and Illumina cetera
around which innumerable destiny's
revolves.
He has realized that vision of his
youth,
he has become one with his idea and you
too will realize the vision,
not the idols of your heart be its base
or beautiful or a mixture of both for
your will always gravitate toward that
what you secretly,
most love NPR hands will be placed the
exact results of your own thoughts.
You will receive that which you earn no
more,
no less.
Whatever your present environment may
be,
you will fall,
remain or rise with your thoughts,
your vision,
your idea.
You will become as small as your
controlling desire,
as great as your dominant aspiration in
the beautiful words of stamp and Davis.
You may be keeping accounts and
presently she'll walk out of the door.
That for so long has seemed to you the
barrier of your ideas and you'll find
yourself before an audience that Penn's
still behind your ear,
the ink stains on your fingers and then
and there shall pour out the torrent of
your inspiration.
You may be blabbing sheep and you should
wander to the city.
Do you call like an open mouth shall
wander under the guidance of the spirit
into the studio of a master.
And after a time he,
she'll say,
I have nothing more to teach you.
And now you have become the master who
did so recently dream of great things
while driving sheep,
the thoughtless,
the ignorant and the indolent,
seeing only the apparent effects of
things and not the things themselves.
Talk of luck or fortune and chance
seeing a man grow rich.
They say how lucky is that was
everything another become intellectual
intellectually exclaim how highly
favored he is and noting that character
and wide influence of another,
they remarked how chance Abe's him at
every turn.
They do not see that trials and failures
and struggles,
which these men have voluntary and
counted in order to gain their
experience.
They have no knowledge of this tech
advice.
If they have made of the undaunted
efforts,
they put forward of the faith.
They have exercised that they might
overcome the apparently insurmountable
and realize the vision of their heart.
They do not know the darkness and the
heartaches.
They only see the light and joy and call
it luck.
They do not have to see the long and
arduous journey but only behold the
present gold and call it good fortune.
They do not understand the process but
only perceived the result and call it a
chance.
In all of human affairs,
there are efforts and there are results
and the strength of the effort is the
measure of the result.
Chance is not gifts,
powers,
material,
intellectual and spiritual possessions,
other fruits of effort.
They are thoughts completed objects,
accomplished visions.
Realize the vision that you glorify in
your mind,
the ideal that you and throne in your
heart this you will build your life.
By this you will become
the remedy.
Calmness of mind is one of the beautiful
jewels of wisdom.
It is the result of long and patient
effort in self control.
Its presence is an indication of ripened
experience and of a more than ordinary
knowledge of the laws and operations of
thought.
A man becomes calm in the measure that
he understands himself as a thought
evolved to be for such knowledge
necessitates the understanding of others
as the result of thought and as he
develops a right understanding and is
more and more clearly the internal
relations of things by the action of
cause and effects a ceases to fuss and
fuel them and worry and grieve and
remains poised,
steadfast,
serene,
calm man.
Having learned how to govern.
He himself knows how to adapt himself to
others and they intern reverence his
spiritual strength and feel that they
can learn with him and rely upon him.
The more tranquil a man becomes,
the greater is his success.
His influence is power for good.
Even the most ordinary trader will find
his business.
Prosperity increases as he develops a
greater self control and equanimity or
people will always prefer to deal with a
man who's demeanor is strongly equable.
The strong common man has always loved
and revered.
It was like a shade giving tree and at
first thirsty land or a sheltering rock
in the storm who does not love a
tranquil heart,
a sweet tempered,
balanced life.
It does not matter whether it rains or
shines or what changes come to those
possessing these blessings go.
They're always cheerful,
poised,
calm.
That exquisite poison oak character
which we call serenity is the last
lesson of culture.
It is the flowering of life,
the footage of the soul.
It is precious wisdom more to be desired
than gold,
even fine gold.
How insignificant mere money looks in
comparison with a serenely joyous life,
a life that dwells in the ocean of truth
beyond the wave,
out of the reach of tempest in the
blesser town.
How many people we know who sour their
lives were ruined.
All that is sweet and beautiful by
explosive temporaries who destroy their
poise of character and make ill will.
It is a question whether the great
majority of people do not ruin their
lives and mother happiness by lack of
self control.
How few people we meet in my life who
are well balanced,
who have the exquisite poise,
which is characteristic of the finished
press.
Yes.
Humanity.
Sturges with uncontrolled emotion is to
Mulch us with ungoverned.
Grief is blown about by anxiety and
about only the wise man.
Only he whose thoughts are controlled
makes the winds and the storms are bay
tempest tossed souls,
whatever you may be under.
What's the weather conditions he may
live no.
This in the ocean of life,
the isles of blessedness,
a smiling and the sunny shore of your
ideal weight.
You're coming.
Keep your hand firmly upon the helm of
thought in the bark of your soul
requires the commanding master.
He does asleep.
Wake him.
Self control is strength.
Thought is mastery.
Calmness is power.
Stay on PR.
Heart peace be still.